highly anticipated new court documents
in the Jeffrey Epstein case have just
been unsealed and everyone is talking
about all the lur details did you know
that Epstein's lawyer visited his house
on multiple occasions did you know that
prince Andrew visited Epstein's island
did you know that Bill Clinton it turns
out has a pension for young ladies yes
you knew that you knew all of that you
and I and everyone broadly knew about
every supposedly new revelation to come
out of the unsealed documents and most
likely that's all we're ever going to
know it's a limited hangout that's a
term of Art in Espionage and public
relations which makes sense because that
is quite clearly what the whole Jeffrey
Epstein drama has been about from the
beginning